plutocracy no it's not when a faithful
dog receives transmissions from a tiny
planet with instructions to enslave
Earthlings latoque receive comes from
the Greek word Pluto's meaning wealth
and kratos which means authority it's a
society ruled by lex luthor richy-rich
and the monopoly guy
it's the 1% ah cracy a word gently
creeping into American consciousness
like a breeze under granny's nighty
highlighted by the recent midterm
elections which were the most expensive
most expensive most expensive
congressional election ever we're
talking 3.7 billion dollars to run TV
and radio ads and those ever
personalized automated voice messages hi
this is Barbara Bush calling for Romney
for president coincidentally there was
also a low voter turnout only 37 percent
of eligible voters went to the polls as
mr. burns would say accident photography
might already be upon us over half of
Congress or millionaires as are eight of
the nine Supreme Court justices that
would have nothing to do with their
ruling on citizens united would it know
the 2010 decision said the government
couldn't limit corporate spending on
elections because it infringes their
so-called First Amendment rights add to
that the McCutcheon decision this year
which got rid of limits on individual
spending and you basically unleashed the
crack in on American democracy that's
why you've got agribusiness dumping 36
million to defeat GMO labeling the
right-wing oil baron Koch brothers
spending a hundred million to get their
guys in office and the financial sector
shelling out four hundred and twenty
million to support candidates allergic
to regulation corruption whether they're
in office are just hovering around DC
like flies around a porta potti a
plutocrat has one goal be a better puta
crack that's why they cut taxes for the
rich give government contracts the
companies they happen to have shares in
and pass free trade agreements to move
your jobs of Bangladesh that bastion of
labor rights they also turn federal
prisons and schools in a private piggy
banks and to top it off they tank the
economy save their own asses with a near
700 billion dollar bailout and wash it
all down with a smooth Kentucky Bourbon
all while proclaiming what's good for
America happens to also be what's good
for me and my golf buddies one
du Midi industry vigilance and it's
probably with the scrooge mcduck
Congress has in store come 2015 so
what's left for the rest of us last time
I checked it was only one vote wasn't
that the idea